it's great to have back on the program
today Abdullah Sharif who is author of
return to Kabul and Afghan Americans
Odyssey in Afghanistan and Sardar from
Afghanistan's golden age to carnage
Abdullah it's so great to have you on
and there's really so much to discuss we
could talk about Afghanistan there are
discussions to be had about Syria maybe
a way to get into all of this is how do
you assess the current administration
the Trump administration's movements of
American troops and military involvement
in the region more generally well I
think that there's a consensus out there
that we are doing things had up without
really understanding what's going on and
that has created a sense of bewilderment
throughout the whole region not only in
the Middle East Iraq and Syria but also
in Afghanistan with a lot of
pronouncements you know what's going on
what's interesting about that is that
it's a completely separate issue from a
broader analysis of if and when the
United States should be involved in the
region and this is something I've been
talking about a lot which is that with
with Syria as an example even if one was
opposed to involvement in Syria of
American troops to begin with it's still
important to figure out what are the
reasons that are precipitating a
withdrawal now because one could have
been against involvement in the first
place but still be concerned about the
forces that lead to a decision to leave
now
let's start maybe with Syria and then
move to Afghanistan
what is your go-ahead yeah so basically
we want to be out of Syria because we
think that Syria is lost to Assad and
also to the Russians
now we have not completely defeated Isis
Isis still out there I just a little bit
in Iraq as well but there's been a lot
of progress made so basically that's why
you want to get out because this was
also a politically motivated
announcement as well because President
Trump had promised his base basically
that he was going to end both
since in Afghanistan so now we are only
about two years away from the elections
so he wants to make good on those
promises there's also the the dynamics
of in the lead-up to the 2016 election
there were allegations from Trump and
the right in America that it's Hillary
who's going to start a war with Syria
that it's Hillary who represents sort of
this systemic neoconservative neo war
hawk risk but what we've actually seen
seems to not really align with that I
mean we have seen certainly that it has
not become action but we've seen threats
or intimations about military action in
North Korea military action in Venezuela
we found out from aides to the president
he was considering and people were
explaining why that that would be a bad
idea so it seems that the political
dynamics are much more complicated than
being for or against military
interventions in the region are they not
yes I think well as you know as Tip
O'Neill later Pulido said all politics
is local and of course it does a very
bad thing I think for our foreign policy
as a whole in national security issues I
think we have to separate you know
what's going on domestically you can
separate 100% but I think we should try
to do the separation as much as we can
and also what's going on in the world
because inevitably as a superpower as
being involved in the globe as a whole
we will regret some of the decisions
that we make today that are politically
based and I think we're going to have to
go back to those areas and spend more
money and more blood and more pressure
to try to fix those areas can you talk
now transitioning a bit over to
Afghanistan President Obama was not able
to / did not get all of our troops out
of Afghanistan Donald Trump talked about
doing that he is indeed going to pull I
believe it's about half of the US troops
that are in Afghanistan but again no
real end in sight at this point from a
geopolitical perspective and then also
from a sort of strategic or military
perspective why is it been so difficult
to get out let me just say there's a
parallel
between both strategies a little bit
because President Obama was very wary
about increasing the surge in
Afghanistan but he listened to the
generals and at the same time Donald
Trump during the election said that he
was being to get out of Afghanistan and
last year he gave a speech and he agreed
to assert a mini search so he increased
you know the number of troops that were
there about 8,000 or so to 14,000 and so
there's a blue apparel there and the
reason there's a parallel there is
because Afghanistan was such a messy
place and it's so difficult to fix that
nobody really knows how to do it so
there's some times that there are hinges
and hope for the best and I think that
there was also a precedent for the surge
that Obama accepted back in 2009 2010
2011 and that had to do with Iraq when
David Petraeus went to Iraq with the
surge it seemed that at least
temporarily that kind of calmed things
down a little bit so we were hoping to
do the same thing in Afghanistan but of
course Afghanistan was not Iraq in Iraq
is not Afghanistan and then so things
have really gotten south ever since then
how do you assess the decision to pull
half the troops from Afghanistan in
light of what has taken place since the
current administration came to power
yeah this is very puzzling to me into a
lot of our observers on Afghanistan
first of all so we have been talking to
the Taliban and we have appointed this
former ambassador to Afghanistan Zama
Helene shot who's also was born in
Afghanistan as the lead negotiator and
while he's negotiating with Taliban we
announced that we are going to withdraw
7,000 of troops that was music to the
ears of Taliban so you know this whole
cliche that you know you have to
negotiate from the position of strength
that just went out the window all of a
sudden and that also and rattled a lot
of people not a lot of people I should
say in Afghanistan itself within the
government and people who are you know
basically the elite living and
and some big cities so I think that the
consensus is that that was a that was a
time at the same time I think that
there's a lot of people who have come to
the conclusion that we are not going to
be able to solve the Afghanistan problem
militarily at some point we'll just have
to you know pick up and leave because
basically it has become a Afghan civil
war it's got a bad dormant but given the
political divisions within the country
it's only the Afghans who are going to
be able to solve their own problems and
I don't think we can do that are there
for them yeah for people who aren't
aware of the internal conflict and
divisions that are taking place in
Afghanistan can you lay out sort of the
the players and the sides that have
developed so they say very briefly it's
long history to this thing but when we
went to Afghanistan 2001 and we tried to
establish some kind of government there
we actually allied ourselves with the
warlords who had militias who helped us
topple the Taliban
so we basically gave the Warlord's
legitimacy and these wars are you know
they very much you know compare of each
others and they've been fighting each
other and so forth not only that that
they had they were very instrumental in
bringing the Taliban back to Afghanistan
because they were just in eluding and
destroying Afghanistan in rating
Afghanistan and so forth so we gave them
legitimacy now this kind of you know
lingered on until the presidential
elections of 2014
when a chef ran he ran against number of
people but the other big vote getter was
a dual habla who's a CEO so we went into
Afghanistan at the time we represented
by John Kerry to to kind of a push the
two warring factions if you were if you
will to making this national unity
government and that national unity
government as held until now and you
know but there's still a lot of
divisions among them to laugh and laugh
in fighting and that means that this
government is not a legitimate
government not only in the eyes of
laughs afghans but also i the falcons
who actually support the Taliban how far
I mean I guess that this question could
be asked morally it could be asked
geopolitically there's a bunch of ways
to assess this but for how long
uh do we have a responsibility to stay
dealing with the problem that we
precipitated or created by our original
actions including when the original
actions were taken by a different
administration than the one that is now
in power I mean how what's your sort of
general assessment of that question well
that's a very difficult question to
really answer I think it has obviously a
political dimension to it
you know we prepare to be in Afghanistan
for a long period of time probably not
the other thing really is is that
Afghanistan should have been weighted is
today I think we mismanaged Afghanistan
by itself but also because you went to
into Iraq so we did have the resources
to make Afghanistan you know to make it
good and then then go to Iraq so we
didn't really have the resources so we
mismanaged this whole thing now
unfortunately I think it's too late the
divisions are there as I mentioned
before these world wars are exploiting
these fault lines between various tribes
and ethnic groups and so forth and at
the end of the day as I don't want to
repeat myself but it would be up to the
Afghans to fix that problem now we also
have other interests in the region and
that's swaying against you know most
Taliban and also Isis which has a little
bit of a foothold in in Afghanistan and
there are terrorist groups who are in in
Pakistan so one will have to make a
judgment as to what is the best way to
stay there or not stay there and how to
fight these threats as well what is the
best way to sort of rebuild I mean I'm
not even sure how to asked when you left
Afghanistan in 1976 so many things about
the country were erector what it is that
we see going on there today and you talk
about you know the Afghani czar going to
have to solve a lot of the problems
that are going on there regardless of
what the US role is or is not what is
the path towards really rebuilding you
know Iraq is also an example where
before the first Gulf War it was just a
totally different place than it is now
how do these rebuilding --zz take place
you know when I was in Afghanistan
working there as a US diplomat I would
go and get a lot of Afghans and what I
would tell them is for you to fix your
country you have to go backwards and
backwards what I meant was that if you
look at the history modern history of
Afghanistan Afghanistan was a viable
nation-state
excuse me definitely between you know
1930s to 1919 70s the ethnic groups
existed the tribal tribes existed but
Afghanistan work as a functional in a
viable nation-state I'll be the poor one
which meant that the leadership that was
there the king and the administration
and Afghanistan had institutions and so
that is why Afghanistan worked so we
need to go back and learn that lesson
and move forward and that's what I was
told
that's all right or till Afghans so
there's not an alien thing if there's a
lot of people here in the United States
and also in Europe who say well you know
this is a very tribal society you know
there are ethnic groups and so forth
you're not going to be able to fix it
that's true and there's all these tribes
are being exploited as I said by these
wards but eventually I think Afghans
will have to decide to reconcile those
differences and make a free honest
another viable a viable nation-state
again I should say based on what you've
seen in terms of u.s. involvement in
Afghanistan now into this second decade
is your sense that there there is a u.s.
role in that rebuilding or that in the
long term it's going to be better for
the u.s. to not be involved you know
Dean's has a role in rebuilding but
unfortunately we chose the right the
wrong side I should say we have poured
in so much money in Afghanistan but we
have not held the people that we
installed in the government accountable
to step up to the plate and do the hair
part for the Afghan it for the Afghan
in terms of building institutions and
since instead in in terms of reading in
corruption nepotism and all the rest so
we have not really held anybody
accountable you know for the all this
effort that has been spent there not
only by us but also the Europeans and
others we've been speaking with abdullah
sharif who is author of return to Kabul
and Afghan Americans Odyssey in
Afghanistan and Sardar from
Afghanistan's golden age to carnage so
great to have you back on the program
today thank you so much for having me on